um so hi everyone my name is Arno which
is basically the French way of saying
Arnold which is more simpler in German
um I'm I've been a data scientist at
sikar for five years and I'm currently
an engineering manager there I'm mainly
working and liking to work on NLP
computer vision scrapping and
unstructured data and I enjoy coffee
like most people get there I guess and
uh Brazilian judicial
you've got my different unders there and
you may know me because I'm working on
sdqdm which is
a streaming progress bar basically
so one other thing I'm interested in is
the fact that as a community we call
ourselves a data scientists but most of
the time we don't even care about the
data part and we never looked look about
it
so that's the reason for my talk I want
to speak about like visualizing
equipment to a vision and why it's
necessary to work on uh on like
basically your products
uh so I'm working on
um into three different categories of
people mainly the data scientists and
VMware engineers and over tech people
that may work on the products the
project team more general marginally
which increa include uh product people
and more business people
and the collaborating team which may be
integration team
labeling sales and other customers
I will start to work to speak about like
data scientists and engineers and the
first thing I'm going to speak about is
a visual debugging uh so one of the
things we tend to run a lot into as data
scientist is what I would call a stupid
errors so things like you just uh didn't
properly normalize data so you're using
float instead of you unsigned ins for
example or you just inverted a burning
box for example X Y and Y X which
happens all the time because every
project does it differently and there is
a ton of things like that so you may
have also RGB and bjr which can produce
blue lettuce for example and it may also
be due to a bad detragmentation another
thing that tends to happen is in a lot
of deep neural network you tends to
normalize or mutant to normalize your
images to have like a fixed size and in
another situation it doesn't even make
sense because you may have product that
things that looks mirror that are
different but look similar if you change
your ratio so for example
okay
so for example one liter bottle and a
smaller one
so but things that make uh occurred
break over time and sometimes it can be
very expensive because we tend to
lose a lot of time if we don't just look
at the image or we even sometimes give
up on experimentation because we failed
it and we didn't notice it
so the first kind of tool you may want
to know you may want to have in a
project is to understand issue with the
code and to be able and your your goal
is to be able to rapidly open an image
with annotation from your console your
notebook or whatever your tool you're
using
and classical tools for that are
basically opencv MacBook Jupiter
notebook
and overs like this
the second thing is we need to look at
is understanding the data and analyzing
experiment
so this is a toaster
and this is not a toaster this is not
just to run into Services an example of
a toaster according to the cocoa data
set which is the most popular Benchmark
in object detection
and he's been using for to compare like
I guess every object detection model so
far uh it's taken from one of the class
but you may find other example like this
I just took toasters the toaster class
because I'm lazy and it's one of the
smallest one so I don't want to like go
through people and stuff like that
and uh what is really surprising it's
there is not just one toaster it was
three of those uh in the validation set
and the training sets so you're not just
like
it's not like something about it's like
a real representative of a small toaster
class it's like 10 percent of your
validation set so basically if you're
better than other people on object
detection on the toaster class it may be
due to that which is probably not what
we want as a community
there is a lot of different unexpected
uh things you may find if you look at
your data so there is this combined
toaster microwave things I didn't even
know existed
it's probably Japanese but I don't know
there is also a classic one which is
painting pictures and seeing an object
through a mirror or window which we may
not want to deal in the same way and it
depends on if you on your use case
uh other classical situation in object
detection is occluded objects uh object
that so far that you will not even able
to identify them so for example those
one but are probably toasters but you
may find harder example in the cocoa
data set and another one that you can
see with oranges there is the fact that
when you tend to have a lot of them on
top of each other at some points it's
basically impossible to label your data
and it turns to this kind of cool labels
so that's things you may have been used
uh in your everyday life and you don't
even know about them
and even if you go in a more rational
approach you've got constantial
different consensual type of toasters
which may be the classical toaster that
most of us know you've got like the oven
toaster which is I think more American
but I'm not sure about that and the
contact rear which we tend to use in
some case in France
and that's not specific to cocoa because
cocoa the Coco the team that build the
coconut acid did its job as good as they
can and that's happened in this kind of
examples are lurking in all the data
sets you may be using
so this is an extract from a talk from
one of the lead at Tesla and he's
basically explaining that they have a
lot of situations that they may not even
expect at first so basically they've got
a case where they've got like a Camion
track carrying trucks that carry trucks
that carry trucks they've got that weird
example with
somebody with a lot of things on his car
or I don't even know if it's a car and
just like a boat and as you may guess it
can mess up a lot with what you
developed
those are taken from imagineet which is
maybe the
I would say the biggest of the most
well-known
data set for all
image classification and so here we have
an example where we tends to fail
because we want a single level for an
image so for example there we've got a
lemon
but it's basically a dog at least from
my point of view and we get a bird but
it's level as an orange for the same
reason
is taken from
um imagenet again so what you have to
know is like imagenet is taken from
images uh from the web and there is a
huge basis in both images it's that like
most of the time uh the tench class is
carried by the Fisher and somebody tried
to try a new way to approach image
classification by using a what they
called bag of local feature so they
basically create a neural classifier and
small crops of images and what they
noticed is that they can
reliably classify turns by just the
fingers of the V Fischer so that's one
of the best way to classify the trench
class
another one is if you look at visual
question answering
uh you may have those kind of question
why you don't so visual cushioning
string is basically trying to answer a
textual question based on the content of
an image and in this kind of case you
don't even don't even need the image
itself because in most cases hero
and that tends to create weird
situations for comparing model in vqa
so you've got people that work on this
kind of situation
another classical one that you may know
about is bad annotations
so basically issue with labeling so
there you've got like a litter box that
has been labeled as a toaster and
[Music]
um
not only has it been labeled as a
toaster but like probably the burning
box is not correct we want the litter
box so that's both issues that may mess
up your your metrics
another one is issue and reward data
itself so under image
so for example you may have a blurry
foggy or overrated camera so in one of a
project we had like a camera that was
just under one of the lights
and because of the heat of the light
the the focus failed and we had like a
really blurry image so just because of a
hit
so this comes into what is known in more
broad engineering as the Pareto
Principle
uh in most situation uh you've got like
80 percent of the situation that may be
explained by 80 by 20 of the causes
and uh the rest of the situation can
come from broad causes
so for example uh if you look at like
the Tesla that that I said you may have
like uh most of the situations are just
a car going into a straight line with no
other cars or people around and then
you've got the weird cases that we've
seen and all of them are different and
are to generalize
so that's a big issue for most of all
projects because
um we tends to have this situation where
we create a proof of concept or MVP and
it's deceptively works because it works
on most of the data and then we've got
this weird example that we cannot deal
with for various reason
and we tend to have a situation where we
work on the project and at some point we
want the situation to improve but we
just talk with this threshold of
performance and in most of the situation
we keep retraining or
increasing the data set size or whatever
and it doesn't do anything because we
don't even try you know experimentation
to understand what is happening and in a
lot of situation
it's not like it's not a bigger model or
something like that that we solve the
issue but trying to understand what is
really happening
so
um a cool tool for data scientists is to
have this ability to explore and
understand the data
and what you want to do is rapidly open
the result of an experiment so for
example training you just did or a new
algorithm and compare the wizard with a
gun Truth Or Another experiment so
classical tools for that as are opencv
Jupiter widgets and two one that I
prefer are streamate and 51.
you may want to create this kind of
visualization that you may I hope will
know of if you've been doing object
detection which is
comparing the gunship running box or
burning box from a previous experiment
with the predicted learning box
and this is how we know if we've
performed well for people that didn't do
object detection
so one of the classical tools to perform
that is using uh stream needs so stream
it is a quick way to create uh
dashboards and over
kind of notebooks and visualization
tools it's really cool because there is
a lot of things that are integrated for
data scientists those those everybody
know what is trim it there or if are
there some people by like a riser fund
okay so you you basically can like write
Python scripts or things that look like
patent script and integrate your model
inside it and just like these favorable
image is easily
so there is a lot of things that you can
do so basically this kind of
visualization where you just uh create
an image with matplotlib or whatever and
you can just display it and then you can
create a bunch of filters and other
things like that
one of the cool Parts about stream unit
is
tightly integrated with most of the
tools you may already be using
it's highly customizable
and it's customizable in a live manner
which I mean by that is you may be
experimenting and looking at that kind
of image and wanting to try a new
visualization because you want to
display something else and you can do
this from your code and then see the
image again without changing everything
or restarting something
another good approach for most computer
vision situation is 51 so 51 is
different in a way because it has
already most of the things you may want
integrated
so we go through like a bunch of the
features for 51 but you don't have to
produce as much code AS we've streamed
basically because if you believe stream
it you kind of have to write everything
so the first thing is you can easily
create
this web interface by just launching the
application on view data set and you can
come from a terminal a notebook or a
console or whatever so you can come from
your Jupiter notebook for example if you
tend to use this
uh and you can display a data set which
is basically
um
51 objects that looks a lot like a
pandas data frame and integrate a bunch
of over functionalities so it's like a
custom things from 51 that you can
produce and use
um
and from that you can just add your
detection by basically taking the
detection and adding it to the sample
and by pressing sample save and
reloading The View you directly have
your new annotation which have you
predictions inside your U of 51u
another cool thing with 51 is it has a
built-in filtering so once you have your
prediction included you already can
filter with for example the confidence
to see uh the example where the model is
the more confident the most confident
and you can do other things to filter by
class or over like a lot of different
way
and which is really really cool with the
51 is you can do everything or most of
the thing from the user interface so
from the web interface but at the same
time from your Jupiter notebook in the
same way and you can interact both way
so please create this weird thing where
you can code in your jupyter notebook or
your python console or whatever you
tends to use
launch the launch the app about on the
data sets do things in the UI and reload
the rest of the UI inside your python
console which is uh awesome so you can
do both thing from the UI most of the
thing from the UI on your python as you
would do but yours can also make it
interact both ways
um as I said there is a bunch of
integrated things that you don't even
have to develop so classic one is the
patch view where you can focus on the
burning box instead of having like the
full View and you can do some things
like filter from different modules and
different predictions
uh there are also pre-made evaluation
tools so for example you can just
compute an evaluate detection between
your grunt roof and your new model and
have results but you can also use them
to directly in the UI try to find the
false positives and errors of your model
so that's a really cool way an easy way
to interact with your data
I don't know if I should plug another
one because it's like really weird
um
there is a lot of other things you can
do so basically you've got this python
this dataset object that looks a lot
like a pandas data frame and you can
like do a lot of students information so
basically if you're interested in
understanding why you are failing on
small burning boxes you can just create
a filter for that and inject it in your
web interface and look at the different
boxes that may be failing
and the re-week one is uh this one so
you can use a model from a model zoo or
from
um or from like your custom models and
uh you can display them and select in
your uh plots interface and then
directly display the results of the
issues uh in your web interface so that
can help you understand various things
about your model edge cases so for
example where they display a few edge
cases the first one is night images that
are on daytime and the reason for that
is rain basically so a more shadowy dark
image
so I have like a case where
a case where you just the camera itself
fell on the the dash cam fail on the
dashboard so you basically don't even
see the the camera anymore
um
and you've got also this case where they
just try to find
annotation Mistakes by looking at
examples that are in the bad Crystal and
so once you've done that you can just
tag them and use them later for
wheelabiting or stuff like that
um
um one thing from my own experience is
it works pretty well in this kind of
case but if you like on really specific
case the uh most models don't works out
of the box to do these kind of things
but you may use your own uh
computer vision model that you've been
training and it kind of make it perform
better
um so next category of people are the
project team
and
what they may want to do is explore the
data set and
what I call create slices
so as anybody heard about slices before
okay
so one of the classic issues that I
already talked about a bit about what is
the case that your data distribution
does not always help you so the classic
case is most of the time you like
driving in a straight line and the
critical situation are very sparse and
very rare so for example you don't want
to run over a pedestrian
and it's not something that happens all
the time in your data set it's actually
where to have like somebody just in
front of your camera
so in self-driving you may want to
isolate those kind of situation
another one is not everything is
equivalent so you got two different uh
case example in there a signpost is
missing a signpost is less important
than missing a car or a pedestrian
and uh missing a car far far away or on
the other side of the world is less
important than missing the car that is
just right in front of you so what we
tend to do as a community is use a big
metric
like the map and just rely on this and
he loves the situation those two bases
that I talked before kind of make us run
into issues when we want to go in the
real world
so a way to contract this is create what
we call slices which is a subset of data
defined by one or more condition which
may be automatic condition
so for example if you look at the Coco
that asset and the map they tends to do
the small small boxes map to the
differentiate them
and you've got and you can also do this
manually
so
a size itself is
um just an easily teacher part of your
data set that you create a new metric on
and you can then compare the situation
and compare metric and specific use case
that may be more important for you or
for your projects
so one of the cool things to do if you
have like a exploration tool is to be
able to locate this kind of use case and
isolate them into places that you can
use then to create those new metrics
that you can monitor
so for this case you want a deploy tool
to be able to search on various metadata
that may not even be your uh you will
model but other models that come from
somewhere else
and so you want to be able to filter on
those and classical tools to do that are
streaming 851 know your data and
surprisingly a lot of labeling tools
that you may already be using
so an example is visual which is a
segments AI which is a labbing tool that
is specialized mostly on video and
segmentation
and what you can do there is you can
locate the images that have been taken
in the city so for example Stuttgart and
where there is a huge numbers of people
that may help you for example understand
if you perform well when you are in a
coded area and if you're not training
into people it may be useful I guess
another one is know your data which is
built by Google so right now you may not
be able to use this on your personal
data set but it's available in a lot of
values
I would say open source data sets so for
example open image
and they provide they provide
huge numbers of metadata that comes from
cloud divisions and over
values things they compute so for
example you may look about look at
exposure quality and you can find bad
images
there is a interesting one so for
example you've got like the safe search
adults but I could not display the
images
that kind of feel this on this stand but
there is surprising images
in open image data sets that you can
find just by working with this kind of
filters
uh so I would take I think another
example of our product team is in a lot
of situation you want to explore on how
to deal with a new feature that you may
not already implement or you may have
issue with the implementation of this
feature
so I'm going to to take an example from
a personal experience
I had this project which we are where we
are to recognize recognize food and
create invoice for people so we just
took a picture and then we said okay you
bought these dishes and we will charge
you this amount for that
um as I'm fresh I'm going to use the
most important example of all which is
baguette
and so we had to invoice bread at some
point
and the first things you may notice is
there is tons of different type of bread
so if you German schwartzport for
example
and you don't want to invoice them all
in the same way for example in France
in a lot of restaurants the First Slice
is free but it's not the case if you've
got like other kind of bread
another thing is
um
the case where where do you have one or
two slices so for example we have this
case where somebody took the full one
the full bread and this case where we
have uh two slices that are smaller but
are stuck together
so all those can create a value
situation where you may fail for these
reasons and you have kind of no chance
to solve them by just like brute forcing
um on your data on your labeling
a new model on your like retraining new
model over and over again
another example is
dishes where you have bread in them so
for example hot dogs and sandwiches
where you don't want to have both the
bread and the
meal itself at um
invoiced
and the last one is this one which is
interesting is in a lot of situations in
a restaurant you may have dips or soups
for example where they give up a slice
of bread for free because you want to
eat your guacamole on bread
so they don't charge you for this and
it's part of a dish even if it's a slice
of bread
okay we're going to the last part which
is uh the collaborating teams
and what you want to do with them is to
share knowledge uh
with labeling and integration teams
mainly but also your sales team
oops
so I'm coming back to the toaster
example and you may already have seen a
lot of these examples in new projects
where
you have a lot of different objects that
are represented by a ladder but maybe
understandable in some case for example
two stars but that may be a lot more
complicated and in this case you have to
train your library team to understand
what it means with examples but at the
same time in a lot of situation you've
got also the integration team that just
came up with your model and I have an
answer that is like basically an
understoodable so the level you choose
as a team but they don't even know what
it means and so they cannot sell it or
they cannot use it in the rest of the
system so a good things to have in this
kind of situation is kind of like a data
dictionary where you can explain
what with examples what we call
references what an image is as a label
and the opposite which is what a text
level is as an image all few images
examples so in this case you may want to
deploy tool with uh in most of in most
situation at least the search based text
and shine kind of to be able to find the
levels and what they can look at images
as images and for labeling teams and for
other people it may be really useful to
have like a visual search engine so that
they can just like kind of ask your
current model or your current
performance your current algorithm what
this weird thing they are seeing is so
that they don't just like give you bad
annotations or waste your time
so you can do this with stream it again
51 and most slabbing tools and the
easiest way to do it really is just like
giving people PDF files with just
examples of your label and the images
so to conclude
um there is mainly two kinds of
categories of usage there are one that
are
for most people there which is for
development teams and you want them
highly coupled with their current tools
so that they can iterate and both see
the images and create filters or other
models and interaction with that
the second part is for
I would say business people or other
teams and you want them to be able to
search a web interface so you want
something that is deployed and not just
running locally
I listed a few important features that
we talked about so that's for later
but it's too boring to go through again
and
those are the two tools that I like the
most which is which are streamlined and
51. stream it is like the highly custom
customizable version uh if you have
specific things to do because your data
is maybe not images or it may be a
combination of images that you may want
to see at the same time or you may want
to shift for example the other thing is
it I think sorry it integrates well with
all the tools you may already have so
for example if you use a DVC data
Version Control for versioning your
models and your weights you can use
stream need to compare
two different predictions by going
through using the python API of data
Version Control DVC and go back to older
predictions of your model
51 is like the easiest one and it has
already a lot of things implemented so
if you're starting it's like probably
the best solution right now
and surprisingly I think most of you
already have those kind of tools
basically things for debugging like
or stuff like that or just in your
current
labeling tools you may be surprised of
what already exists in them
and to conclude so please look at your
data that's really important that's in a
lot of situation the best way to
understand why you're not improving why
you're stuck on that selling
and yeah don't make this toaster sad and
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Arno for this great talk you
were pretty fast we have some minutes
left
but before we let you go into coffee
break and all our attendees
please answer on following questions
these people were writing on slido
first question
what belt do you have in BJJ
I'm blue belt I'm a blue world yeah
can you change annotations with 51
um
I think no but you can
right now I'm pretty sure you cannot but
you can tag them so you can add a level
to them and you've got like a lot of
tutorials that explains how to interact
with most labeling tools so for example
they
they have a tutorial to interact with
cvrt and a lot of the tools that you
already may be using easily
can 51 handle big cocoa data sets with a
lot of bounding boxes per image and
thousands of images
I don't think I ran into any troubles
with Coco I'm not sure why that's a good
question I'm surprised maybe due to my
computer or some things I may miss but I
think they are using directive images
from the web and not like downloading
them but I'm not sure about that that's
a good question
I'm sorry
the last question I have here is how
much do you work with data as an
engineering manager and how does the
data science skills help you in your
engineer manager role oh
[Music]
um
I think one of the things I tends to do
a lot is
like trying to wake
um like over data scientist up to this
so in love situation
uh they don't care as much as they
should and there is a thing that is very
specific to sicar because I didn't
present what we do we are a consulting
firm so we build values Data Solutions
for people and so one of the things that
arise because of that is we tend to
start a lot of projects and uh
for this we have to create the first
data sets and one of the things I tend
to do is like
go get this data find people to take the
pictures for example I was in the sea
company in
2015 and one of the funny things I could
see at that point was Google cars like
Google employees who are doing Google
class everywhere to create the first
self-driving data sets and as a
community I think we tends to be lazy in
a way and not try to find Solutions and
push data set creations
so that's the things I do a lot with
data is complaining with my fellow team
there's one more question upcoming or
some people
try to write them down now if there is
this special
tool story you can recommend to
visualize time series data
oh no sadly I'm not really good at that
I think you can like you can do most of
what you
I assure you there with three minutes
and your current
plot
tools that's what we do in one or four
projects but I don't have like a
equivalent to 51 where everything is
integrated but you can like build
whatever you want with swimming which is
really cool
okay thank you for answering all these
questions
to all of you have a great coffee break
can we get some Plus for ano
[Applause]
thank you